we are indeed with Brian Woods who is
the director the music director at the
World Chess Hall of Fame Brian first of
all welcome to the show tell us a bit
about what you do at the workshops Hall
of Fame sure thank you for having me
um I'm a concert pianist by by trade so
uh what I I've trained at the Royal
Conservatory in Toronto I'm based here
in St Louis and so what I do personally
is I travel to the United States and I
perform solo recitals and I do solos
with orchestras so that's what I do but
but at the road test Hall of Fame what I
do is I lead the classical programming
at the witch off as we call it for World
chest Hall of Fame which off music
series so alongside my co- music
director Brian Owens who does the
non-classical programming we program two
concerts a month that you can come and
see here at the Royal Chess Hall of Fame
featuring musicians from all over the St
Louis area in all genres of music so on
the classical end which is what I do I
partner with the St Louis Symphony area
groups I myself perform on occasion and
we put on concerts
every month and so we get to hear from
Opera groups string quartets solo
pianists wind quintets all kinds of
ensembles of music that you can come and
enjoy at the World Chess Hall of Fame
speaking of you performing as well let's
take a look at one of your research
performances
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tell us a bit about that night how are
the emotions that night well I couldn't
hear exactly what was in the clip but
I'm guessing it was Chopin that I was
playing from what I was looking at and
that was the debut of my concert
wanderings which is a concert that I've
been touring around the United States
and you can learn all more about this at
Brian woodspians.com which is where you
can learn about me as a performer but I
debuted this concert with rexinkfeld in
the audience who is this incredible
supporter of everything that happens
here at the roaches Hall of Fame and
there was a lot of pressure that night
it was all new music for me I'd never
played this music before in public it
was the entirety of the Chopin for
balads which are some of the most
dramatic and challenging pieces in The
Pianist repertoire so a little bit of
pressure but it was it was an exciting
night and it was a an incredible event
and it's all on YouTube if you if you
want to watch it at the World Chess hall
of fames YouTube channel so all there
for you to see and you guys performed
the piece during the sinkfield Cup
Opening Ceremony as well tell us a bit
about that so Brian Owens came up to me
or approached me over email about a week
before the sink fold cup happened and he
said look we're planning this original
piece that was based on Bobby Fischer
and it I didn't really know what it was
it was he sort of handed me a piece of
music and I said I'm not sure how this
all fits in I showed up the day of the
opening ceremony we we met about two
hours before the ceremony started and it
was this very almost um hamilton-like
kind of presentation of a a moment in
Bobby Fisher's life involving uh hip-hop
and piano playing and a band and so we
got to perform this for everyone who was
there for the opening ceremony the
single cup and it just could not have
been more exciting that kind of live
feel of putting something together that
was new you know I'm In classical music
I often put together things that are
very old so this was an exciting thing
for me to work on something that was so
new and so fresh it's felt like you guys
were playing together for a lifetime you
said you met two hours before and you
put that together that's in yeah that's
nice of you to say I mean we we really
uh with musicians at this level I think
we're so accustomed to putting together
things very quickly and very last minute
so that was the um the excitement about
it but I mean I say it was last minute
he'd been putting a lot of time and
energy into it I was just as I said sort
of a cog in the machine but it was a fun
night talk to me about the music series
uh can the public join absolutely and
and we actually have a concert coming
this week um the winter Opera St Louis
is coming on this Thursday night October
13th and that's at 7 p.m we have our
concerts with a an artist talk at 6 pm
and
um the tickets are still available I
encourage folks to head to worldchess
hof.org and slash programming there's
that tab at the top of the screen that
you can check out all the things that we
have going on at the World Chess Hall of
Fame but that's a concert that's
happening this month just last month we
had the string quartet which is an
incredibly famous string quartet here in
St Louis that performed specifically for
us at the World Chess Hall of Fame so
there's so much going on and and tickets
are still available for concerts that
are happening this month so I would
encourage everyone to check it out Brian
thank you very much for joining us guys
any questions oh yes oh yeah
most definitely Brian one of uh the
secret Pleasures I have in life as a
chess Grandmaster is when I walk past a
chess Hustler and he says you know let's
play for ten dollars and I think to
myself death is walking by this this
great movie shine where in the movie
there's the piano bar scene he comes in
and he starts playing and it's just
absolutely brilliant have you ever
walked into a bar everything's quiet sat
down on the piano and just wowed
everybody into submission silence and
then magnificent Applause is that
something that happens for you uh
sometimes I would say I I will say in
the Rome airport one time I was coming
back from a performance there and there
was a piano in the in the airport in
Rome and I started playing some
Beethoven and and folks sort of gathered
and I suppose it was a similar situation
right
um I can't say I played I played the
Flight of the Bumblebee like he did and
in that in that bar and shine but it was
definitely a similar experience and it's
always fun because you always run into
music lovers that you would not expect
out in public which is really what we do
as musicians it's for it's for others so
that's that's always a fun time
wonderful much much success in
everything you do here in St Louis and
good luck on your career thank you very
much absolutely I was wondering actually
if you if you place some chess
yes I mean now that you've got
your accomplished Music musician I know
how's your Catalan folks outside I said
I I played I played some with my brother
when I was a kid but it's been some time
and I I'm afraid I'm embarrassed myself
it's time to learn something
there's a lot in common between
musicians and chess that's fine
especially with just it just um you know
the strategy of it all and just the
mental focus that you have to have in a
performance in a chess match there's
there's so much overlapping and so we
like to say you know there's that same
kind of black and white Vibe with the
piano keys and the and the chessboard as
well and and it it works so well
together so you wouldn't imagine that
these two things would be you know uh
perfect Partners but it works out
incredibly well exactly
loves music and classical music as well
I don't know if you have visited
performances in the Hall of Fame but he
is it should be should definitely be the
one from players yeah we do a great we
do actually there's always a couple
Grandmasters who like to show up to a
lot of our a lot of our concerts I think
um you know oftentimes chess players or
music lovers and there's a lot of famous
composers that are all of our chess
players and so like I said there's just
so much overlap and it's such a delight
to see that all come together at the at
the World Chess Hall of Fame thank you
so much thank you Brian again good luck
uh and with the concert coming up